[Music]
no one knows who came up with the idea
of squeezing oranges to make juice
the popularity of orange juice increased
dramatically in the middle of the 20th
century as techniques were developed to
extend its shelf life
today many people start their day with a
tall glass of oj
in its purest form orange juice is fresh
squeezed and made with no preservatives
or other additives
the appeal is indisputable
fresh-squeezed oj contains vitamin c and
the flavor is authentic
orange juice production starts in groves
the trees take several months to bear
fruit and are harvested in early
november
picking oranges is a job that's done
entirely by hand an automated picking
system could damage both the trees and
the fruit
the picker uses a bag made of vinyl
composite that's lightweight and heavy
duty
there are multiple types of juicing
oranges
this one is called the hamlin
hamlin oranges are small and juicy the
trees they grow on are productive and
resilient to cold
the picker plucks the fruit from the
trees before they turn orange
they may be green on the outside
but they are still sweet on the inside
the fruit size and condition are
indications of maturity and flavor
as the picker empties the bag into a bin
he examines the oranges
anything with tears or punctures may
also have internal degradation
but superficial flaws won't affect the
quality of the juice
the oranges are taken to a processing
facility and transfer to a sloped chute
the gradient of the chute prevents
damage
as the oranges tumble into a wash
station
a sprayer sprays soapy water onto the
oranges as spiraling nylon brushes scrub
and clean while simultaneously moving
them forward
[Music]
after the wash another sprayer rinses
them off as the spiraling brushes
continue scrubbing
[Music]
the oranges transition to a roller
conveyor that takes them up and under
drying fans
as the oranges exit the dryer
an inspector checks them for any missed
damage
[Music]
the oranges travel across more revolving
brushes
the bristles on these brushes are
gentler than on the first group
they buff the skin of the fruit and
remove any residual dirt
finally the oranges fall off the
conveyor line into a bin
now cleaned the oranges can be juiced
with no contaminants that could spoil
either the product or juicing machinery
as a final precaution the juicing
operator performs one last inspection
if she's completely satisfied with her
cleanliness and general condition
she loads the oranges into the extractor
there's no need to slice them beforehand
she feeds them to the juicing machine
hole
the system feeds the oranges one at a
time to the extractor
the extractor punctures the fruit and
metal teeth peel away the skin
it squeezes out the juice while
simultaneously filtering out the seeds
and the membrane between the flesh of
the orange and the skin
the juice flows into a vat
a screen in the vet filters the pulp to
the desired consistency
there are several different filters for
different amounts of pulp
the juice is bottled in jugs
the plastic jugs will accommodate any
expansion of the unpasteurized juice due
to fermentation
instead of pasteurizing this fresh
squeezed juice it is chilled immediately
the unpasteurized orange juice won't
have an extended shelf life but the
trade-off is an unaltered flavor and
color
refrigeration will preserve the juice
for a few days and after all fresh
fresh-squeezed orange juice is a drink
that's best served cold